the Joe Rogan experience what here goes
first up what is gels that's the second
one a person versus stupid obnoxious is
number one
a woman's genitals I mean who says
sticking in my [ __ ] like during sex I
mean that'd be a nightmare that would be
cuz what's after that like where do you
go from there if that Oh what you open
with when a girl says put it about cuz
it's got to Charing like what is what
are you saying
why are you saying it like that even
evenly Oh [ __ ] is so aggressive and
sometimes you have to button you can't
say penis right yeah put your penis in
me yeah
alright I so do a bit about the word
[ __ ] that sounds like it's wearing a
sombrero and carrying a gun does [ __ ] oh
it's just like it sounds manly weird
comment it is [ __ ] manly word what
penis slizz it's too it's too soft
penis hey cuz I can't get you at my
penis can I put my penis in your Slithe
yeah it's like my penis what do you
think of my penis penis penis it's just
I also vagina my girl says my vagina we
think of mom what it's too clinical
it is but it's okay cuz it's like you
could have like you could a girl can say
that I think I think right here I think
sending a girl at dick pic and I know
I'm opening a floodgate with this but
try not to be an animal about it folks
if you send a girl an unrequited dick
pic and you just write what do you think
about my penis she's gonna no one gets
more dick pics than Whitney I told her
that she needs to write like a book and
publish all these just blur out
everybody's face and publish all these
dick pics she shares us know leave the
digs she shares him to us in this group
text and I mean with her she like it's
me and daliyah and Schwartz and and
she'll send us his pictures these guys
send her we're all like you got to write
a book
write a book have using so many there's
an app that blurs out part of the
picture to make it look like your dick
has been blurred out oh it's awesome
like if you're just in and then I'll
just put a blur thing next to your leg
do
you see that one dude that they took
down his photo on Instagram and all he
was doing he was wearing shorts just a
really muscular gentleman with a large
hog and he was wearing shorts and
they're like like boxer briefs and his
dick was so big that you could see it in
in the boxer briefs
so Instagram took down his [ __ ] photo
now that's not cool a dick in briefs as
per restriction it is shrouded and it
should be rounded good way to put it
yeah and it should stand you are on
point with the vocabulary in this
podcast so there what the famous jason
derulo yes you said I didn't see this
knowledge that googled it's real reason
and dude the guy's got a big hog he's a
very well-built gentleman all-around
very muscular and handsome with a large
hog put the photo up right now drew over
there look at that sleeve this gentleman
first of all what does this guy do
he's a singer Just Answer gonna be the
new cats that's what he does he's gonna
be the new cats how the [ __ ] is a guy
that manly in any way you can't you can
see by the outline of the heart oh my
god yeah that's quite a hard look at but
you know what it's not terribly you
gotta look for it's not terribly
prominent it's not she's not have had
that taken down what is he gonna do he's
good you got a problem because he's got
a big dick is that really what's getting
it taken down who complained some
[ __ ] he should put it back and just
blur it out did he put it back up did he
blur it I don't know I could see she
just put it back the way it is really
should protest it he should it's
nonsense
I'm with that got shredded with a large
hog congratulations sir
in Australia with a large hog yeah he's
shredded with a large amount the
American dream it is the American dream
he's you're [ __ ] on the American
dream Instagram you're on Americans if
you don't like a shrouded hog he did
covered up what he did pixelated he put
a big cat he put another dick over I do
[Laughter]
what a Subway sandwich there that's
[ __ ] hilarious yeah I don't
he should be congratulating ons physique
as well that's some long hours in the
gym right yeah that is some high weight
low rep yeah
a hundred percent that that dude is that
dude is working out yeah it's working
out that's doing [ __ ] and showing his
hog what is the problem folks is that
when we're scared of hogs behind cloth
also who says social media has to be a
bastion of purity yeah right
Twitter's no garbage wasteland I love
Twitter for that Twitter shows all kinds
of [ __ ] and sucking and chaos maybe
because Facebook owns it I don't know
probably yeah I think they just don't
want porn on it they don't want porn in
and most of like really violent [ __ ]
are there hidden like you have to click
on I'm okay with that because I follow a
lot of like nature accounts and maybe
today I don't want to see a baby seal
Club you know and it's good to know that
those images are there so it's present
in your mind but define porn is that
porn and that guy's not porn right so
what's where do we draw the line here
[Applause]